I think we've had this conversation but
it's like it's hard to tell your kid to
like love themselves as they are when
you've cut up your face so many times
yeah absolutely
it's like oh yes you're perfect the way
we are but Mom I think what about you
it's like let's not talk about that like
how do you justify that you know how do
you justify that you know how do you
tell your kid it's okay to be short if
you got in height surgery like
that's going to be a hard one
kids look at your ex before they listen
to your words
you know and I don't know I I love all
these feel-good messages that everyone
says which pretty much alleviates any
accountability people have for their
choices it sounds great nobody needs to
be responsible cool when you pass it on
to folks who don't care for any of that
who see how you actually move
they know it's [ __ ] we all know it's
[ __ ] yeah there's a lot of things
like about the
Botox right now you're not supposed to
ask a woman is like or top mid comments
I've seen like a bad personality like
yeah uh
it's not in your business what we put in
our face and stuff like that and I'm
like I couldn't care okay concur it's
not of our business because there's some
people that will go out of their way to
ask oh my God she needs to slack on the
botox she need to slack on the lip
fillings and the lip fillers and stuff
like that yeah concur it's none of
nobody's business I understand that but
then when you turn around and you got a
kid not having confidence in there in
yourself because they look at you and
they look at the mirror and they're like
[ __ ] I don't look like that
how you gonna make
that's the that my mom look good I don't
look like my mom I don't look good so
how are you gonna explain that to your
kids it's hard it's hard even that even
as a man man started to have like men
are starting to have more and more
surgeries and stuff like that like yeah
how how are you gonna same same like
it's more prevalent with women but even
with men it's starting to be like more
like that hair transplants are
everywhere now huh hair transplants
give me a number bro yeah I could put
you in touch some people if you want go
to Turkey hey turkey yeah I think it
involves them like literally poking a
bunch of things and they literally
implant hair yeah
that's what they did your hair but it's
just like they're poking a bunch of
posts like they would take
hair out of your ass we'll see you yeah
and you know I mean you got mad here
everywhere
you don't got no hair on Jazz I said
mm-hmm I I confirmed yeah everybody got
here
um but some some people got more hair
than others on the whole thing is I
think that's funny when people say
it's none of your business because to me
it's like on one hand folks blame
society for any beauty standards that
folks have to conform to on the other
hand it's nobody's business it's like
those two things can't exist at the same
no right like
you are making choices as a result of
society but the society cannot comment
on the choice you're making no what what
is something that's not it works none of
that makes sense and also I hate the
fact that everyone's so tone deaf about
this stuff or they're just like we're
not talking about it because I'm like
these beauty standards are not born in a
vacuum no they're coming from somewhere
that is a societal thing that works
absolutely and nobody was trying to look
like this 30 years ago all right and
nobody just sprouted this idea from no
[ __ ] nowhere and then everyone else
on Instagram had the same idea so
clearly there's a tremendous amount of
influence involved in pushing people to
do these choices so we should be having
constant discussions about that I'm not
here to be bragging on an individual and
be like you [ __ ] I don't care like
that go do whatever you want to do at
the end of the day it's your choice but
let's talk about what these things mean
in a greater context
and think about
what are we pushing people to do because
people getting surgery is younger and
younger I know women going to [ __ ]
random hotel rooms in Atlanta and
getting horse needles in their ass
dbl's most dangerous surgery right now
in the world absolutely so many people
are dying from them so it's like we
should be talking about them it's not
it's not no no in business I don't have
to go in on you as an individual I'm not
trying to shame any one person I'm
talking about what does this mean and
where are we going yeah because I think
I'll just finish by this point yeah go
ahead in five years ain't nobody gonna
have the original faces no definitely
not what I don't speak the lady
specifically you know on Instagram and
you're like I thought I knew you who's
this
that's what it's going to be absolutely
and it's
you can't be outraged at these little
girls out there that feel the way they
feel with their body and they're doing
all types of things you know either
motivating themselves or or or doing
like bulimia or making themselves throw
up and having all these things in your
face
you're part of the problem you're
promoting that
the beauty sensors and [ __ ] like that
well you're doing the same thing you
cannot be outraged and be like you know
what there's little girls out there or
it's really [ __ ] up we need to do
something and blame the magazines and
stuff like that when you post yourself
with your favorite is fixed yeah you
could be like you could be talking [ __ ]
about the Kardashians and stuff like
that because they're they're they're
using all these fillers and they're
using all these filters and stuff like
that but you do the same thing you are
also part of the problem you are
contributing so
here's the weird part about this I feel
like everyone is both the victim and the
perpetration yep that's and that's
possible yeah that is possible well I
mean you cannot have these beauty
standards and not be the victim to it
because you have to conform to something
so yeah you know what I'm saying you
didn't come up with it yet so you were
also afraid of that you know so that's I
think the reason why I don't condemn
individuals because I'm like yes you
perpetuate it but you're also a victim
to it you have to have enough insecurity
in you in regards to how you look to
feel like I'm gonna only feel better if
I conform to that that means you're a
victim of something right uh but at the
same time via that choice and you
publicizing it to everyone you are then
telling everyone like yeah you I did it
to me I feel better